everyone this is
grand master ben feingold with my best
move
now this game was played over 30 years
ago i'm sorry
almost 30 years ago and i guess i
haven't made any good moves since
um so i have the black pieces and this
was a sicilian defense
and i think it's important to show you
the last move of my opponent
that might give you some context my
opponent's bishop
was uh on e on e3
in this position and he didn't want to
lose his
dark scored bishop so he decided to move
it
and i think his move is is pretty
reasonable he played bishop to g5
and he doesn't mind trading bishops in
fact if i take
his bishop bishop takes g5 he takes with
the queen
his queen's in a pretty menacing
position um although that move is okay
too
but that wouldn't be my best move okay
so in this position i want to give you
my thought process
because the move that i played is um
seems very difficult to find and my
thought process was
i'd like to play bishop before
uh winning his queen as queen's pinned
but
that doesn't work because he plays c3
blocking my bishop
so i realized if his c pawn wasn't there
i could play bishop b4 winning his queen
okay
and then uh i also realized
if i took his bishop he has to take with
the queen
there's nothing else he can recapture
with so if his queen isn't there
i can win the bishop and then all of a
sudden it came to me
sort of lucky that the queen and the
pawn
protect the same square d3
so then i was like well can i play
knight d3 check
it seems like i can't but you know i'll
look for a second it's check
so and it turns out i did play knight d3
check
and i'm not sure if that's the best move
i ever played but it's definitely the
most surprising
and well i've already discussed if he
takes with the c
pawn i play bishop b4 winning his queen
if he takes with the queen
i can take his bishop getting his dark
squared bishop after all
so the only move i'm scared of is bishop
takes d3
and it's just lucky for me that i have a
move that wins my piece back
and gives me a big advantage the queen
which heretofore was hiding on b8 now
comes in with great vengeance and
furious anger
queen e5 check and we got a little fork
here
and he can't play bishop e3 because i
can still take it so i get my piece back
and i get a big advantage because i have
two bishops and all the dark squares
so knight d3 check is computer approved
and uh in this position uh
after thinking quite a long time my
opponent played
uh king f1 and
i'm not winning material but i'm pretty
sure my opponent doesn't want to play
king
f1 when he can castle either way and now
he can't
and so now i saved my knight moving my
knight away from d3
with black has a very nice advantage and
i ended up winning a nice game
that was round one of a new york open
and the funny
story is i won like a hundred dollars
that tournament
and my opponent won several thousand
dollars
he got clear first under 2400 he won a
good class prize
and he got a good lesson so knight d3
check
that's my best move and even though it
was about 28 years ago
i still enjoy looking at it i hope
you're enjoying the candidates
i hope this was almost as good as the
games you're seeing but probably not
and i'll see you guys when we make other
videos bye everybody
[Music]
so
you